pedro castillo tiene la soga al cuello
el ex secretario presidencial de perú
bruno pacheco que se encontraba prófugo
de la justicia hasta el martes presentó
ante la fiscalía una lista escrita a
puño y letra' por el mandatario para
realizar los ascensos y bajas en las
fuerzas armadas y la policía nacional un
documento que pone en evidencia el
presunto tráfico de influencias una de
las cinco investigaciones que pesan en
contra del jefe de estado del país
andino pero casi no debe ser destituido
porque la polis una razón bien sencilla
porque se está comprobando que es
alguien que usa su poder para construir
impunidad frente a las investigaciones
de corrupción que se le están haciendo
castillo también se enfrenta a
investigaciones por presunto tráfico de
influencias en la compra de combustible
por parte de la empresa estatal
petroperú corrupción y colusión agravada
en un proyecto de obra pública plagio en
su tesis electoral y obstrucción a la
justicia en la destitución de un
ministro del interior de momento no
puede ser acusado y juzgado ya que está
protegido por su inmunidad presidencial
hasta el final de su mandato en 2020
pero estas situaciones ya se ven
reflejadas en la opinión popular pues
alguien más que nos ha venido engañar
bueno que engañó a muchas peruanas
muchas peruanos y que lamentablemente no
no debería continuar y el contrario está
perjudicando más la situación porque
gracias a su mal manejo a la mala gente
que está poniendo la situación se está
complicando aqui en el peru entonces
particularmente considero que no no
debería seguir que es actualmente
manchado en corrupción la última
encuesta realizada por ipsos indica que
pedro castillo tiene una opinión
negativa del 74 por ciento de la
población cuatro puntos más que en junio